it's been two years since the pandemic
and the world is slowly recovering from
kovid 19.
currently
on november 26 2021 world health
organization
has reported one shocking news
they have found one variant of kovid 19
known as b 1.1.529
which they have named as omicron
and now this is a variant of concern
after this news there were several
question in people's mind
such as whether this variant
would be
neutralized by existing vaccines
can this variant be detected with qrt
pcr
is it more dangerous than another
variant is it more transmittable all of
these questions would be answered in
this video
so stay tuned till the end and share
this video with your friends to grow
awareness
worldwide more than 30 countries have
reported the presence of omicron and now
there are more than 370 cases reported
worldwide india also reports two cases
of omicron and one of them was shocking
in order to understand why it was
shocking stay tuned till the end of this
video
now let us talk about the propagation of
any virus in a population when virus
propagates in a population and reproduce
they eventually accumulate mutations
these mutations could be beneficial for
the virus or these mutations could be
disadvantageous for them
if the mutation is not really useful for
the virus that particular variant would
be eventually eliminated from the
population
but if it is advantageous this virus
would grow and reproduce more increasing
number and eventually it would become
the variant of concern
now
world health organization has
designated one
dedicated advisory group
for
determining
the evolution of sars covid2 virus and
its variants
so this particular
group
mod periodically monitors the behavior
of this virus and also reports the
mutations that are present in the
population
and they have reported that recently
there is a new variant
coming out from south africa
previously there were lots of variants
like alpha gamma delta beta and we all
kind of
know all of these right but the recent
variant is omicron question is whether
it is more transmittable or more
dangerous
and also we don't know how fast the
transmission could happen
now the number of people tested positive
has risen really fast in south africa
and that's why people think that there
is a
faint correlation between incidence of
omicron and the increase in number of
kovid cases
but there is no data to support that
there is a direct correlation between
these two
now the question is can omicron be
detected using normal rtpcr test normal
rtpcr test generally detects or reports
the presence of virus by looking at the
viral specific gene
an answer is yes
rtpcr test can give us some idea about
presence of omicron but sequencing
result is essential for confirmatory
test
now let us try to understand how the
rtpcr test for omicron would work
before that we have to understand how
rtpcr test for a general kovid variant
works
so generally in order to say kovid
positive
one technician or scientist has to
report several signature of the corona
coronavirus
and these signatures include rdrp
e-protein n-protein or s-protein
more than one signatures has to be
present in the patient sample in order
to designate it as covid positive
now the mutation in omicron is
accumulated in the gene encoding for s
protein or the spike protein
due to this mutation scientists suspect
that the s gene might not get amplified
in the rt pcr test
and they found that in many patients
there was a dropout
or the target failure in case of s gene
so when the patient samples were
examined using qpcr
they found
the patients who have
kovid-like symptoms they show signatures
like rdrp e-protein or n-protein but in
the same
patient
s protein could not be detected
so moral of the story is
s gene target failure could be a new
signature
for omicron
but this is a putative assay it's not
confirmatory
once there is a suspect
then sequencing results would confirm
the presence of omicron virus
now according to italian uh
medical group this is the structure of
the viral spike protein
you can see in the omicron variant
there is quite a lot of mutations which
has been accumulated in the active site
active site means the site which
interacts with the human receptor and
allows the virus to enter the human cell
so what we really know
is the gene encoding the spike protein
is heavily mutated but what we don't
know
as a result of this mutation whether the
affinity towards affinity of the spike
protein towards the s2 receptor would
increase or not this is really unknown
so we kind of know half the story not
the full story
now the group of paul beniers from
rockefeller university
give out a interesting research
and the link is provided in the
description
but before understanding that let me
tell you that whenever our body is
infected with covid our body tries to
respond by creating antibodies against
this virus
eventually the antibodies would
neutralize this virus and eliminate the
viral infection
now
these group of researchers has
engineered a virus
with mutated version of kovid's spike
protein but this particular virus is not
dangerous or not a threat to human
population because it is incapable of
causing kovid19
water relax but
anyway
this particular virus
is an important study tool
now these researchers has taken
serum samples and isolated the
antibodies from vaccinated individuals
and incubated that vaccine with this
particular engineered virus or
polymutated virus
and what they found out to their
surprise is that
antibodies from the patient sample or
these vaccinated individual cannot
really neutralize this particular
variant or this polymutant spike protein
variant
shocking enough
many mutations which are present in this
polymutant variant is also present in
omicron
that kinds of tell us that omicron would
be very dangerous like this polymutant
variant and it might evade our immune
system
but this is a prediction based on
experimental result
we don't have enough evidence to suggest
anything conclusive yet
now
preliminary data suggests that there was
an increasing rate of hospitalization in
south africa in last week
now there could be multiple reason
behind it
this particular hospitalization might
have nothing to do with omicron
it is also possible that there was an
overall increase in kovi 19 cases and
that's why there was an increased
hospitalization and it has nothing to do
with omicron as per specific
but we still don't know the actual
result it is not clear whether this
infra infection with omicron would be
resulting in a more severe disease
compared to
other variants or not
and only time will tell us that
doctors are confused
they also have many questions in their
mind
like is it a particular age group group
which is more susceptible to this
infection
whether males or females are equally
vulnerable or not will vaccination
prevent the severe infection and
mortality
whether antibodies present in the
patient body can neutralize omicron
variant all of these questions are
unanswered at this moment and we don't
have sufficient data to back any of
these questions
right now
it is also possible that omicron is more
transmissible than the other variants
but that doesn't mean that it would be
causing more severe infection
it is also possible that it is more
transmissible but less severe infection
is caused by omicron so both
possibilities are there
anyway who has recommended usage of
corticosteroids and il-6 receptor
blockers
in case of severe infections
in india there were two cases and one of
the case was really shocking the patient
number two was
66 year old male who had a travel
history from south africa
but the shocking news came from patient
number two who was a 46 year old doctor
and he had no trouble history from south
africa
then how the hell he was affected by
omicron
and one of the leading india's newspaper
reports this news
now this question is
that how does he got affected
is this variant already present in
indian population
and what is even more shocking that his
five primary contacts were tested kovid
19 positive
so is it the case that already
already omicron variant was present in
indian population and now after
designating this as an omicron we
understand that there might be presence
of this omicron virus
or we are panicking at this moment so
the truth is not understood yet
it's very hard to predict it's very hard
to investigate
but what we can do right now
is wait for the scientist to give us any
conclusive answer
now what we can do possibly is covering
our faces and elbows with napkin or with
our
with with our elbow while sneezing and
coughing
so all the kovid hygienes like washing
our hands with soap sanitizing hands
avoiding crowded places
and this should be followed right now
because
we should not be
panicking in this situation but also we
should know that prevention is much
better than cure
right
so
we should count on our doctors and
scientists to give us more information
and at this situation we should spread
awareness and not panic so i hope this
video was useful to you if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up if you
think this video was useful share with
you share it with your friends and
family and help to grow awareness thank
you